تطلعاته ادماجي اوكرانيا في منظومه الامن
الاوروبيه الاطلسيه تتصدر اهتماماته قمه
الحلفاء في ليتوانيا المجاوره لبيلاروسيا
بولندا ودولو البلطيق تدافع بحماسه شديده
من اجل ضم اوكرانيا لعضويه الحلف دون تاخر
انتهى زمن التكرار الوعود وقد حان الوقت
كانتفق على خطه واضحه بشان تنفيذ هدف
عضويه اوكرانيا لا خيار امامنا سوى اطلاق
رساله قويه حول مستقبل عضويه اوكرانيا
التي تصارع الثعبان الروسي منذ اكثر من
عام ونصف العام
قمه النيتو ستعلن عن قرارات ملموسه لتعزيز
الرضع والدفاع عن الحلفاء ضد روسيا في
ثلاثه اقاليم جغرافيه هي اقليم الشمال حيث
يمتد من القطب الشمالي الى هولندا واقليم
الشرق لحمايه دول وسط اوروبا وسفح الشرقي
للحلف واقليم المتوسط والبحر الاسود في
الجنوب
القمه ستعلن عن خطوات اضافيه لتعزيز
الدفاع والردع منها ثلاثه مخططات اقليميه
مدعومه من قوه ذات جاهزيه عاليه تعدادها
300 الف جندي وقدرات هائله في مختلف
مجالات الدفاع قمه النيتو تستضيف الرئيس
الاوكراني وكذلك الشركاء في منطقه المحيط
الهادي وهم زعماء كل من استراليا
ونيوزيلندا وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
شراكه تثير انتقادات الصين
الجدل القائم حول عضويه اوكرانيا في حلف
شمال الاطلسي لا يحجب اطلاقا الدعم
العسكريه لاوكرانيا في الحرب الجاريه
والخطه التي ستعلن عنها القمه من اجل
اعادته بناء قوات اوكرانيا وفق مواصفاته
جيوش حلف الناتو في انتظار موعد العضويه
ربما بعد نهايه حرب اوكرانيا الطويله
نور الدين الفريد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات